the establishment media repeated an
apparently false story about donald
trump
four months a 13 year old black kid is
shot by police in chicago prompting more
talk about the evils of the police
and the democrats are looking to pack
the supreme court i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first a quick reminder you're
spending hundreds of dollars
too much on your cell phone bill if you
are not using puretalk usa which is why
thousands of customers
have been canceling the nation's largest
wireless providers because they found
out they can get the same service at
half the price by switching over
to puretalk usa a lot of my listeners
are doing exactly this
that's right instead of charging obscene
fees to pay for the massive mainstream
media campaigns and corporate campuses
and retail outlets across the country
puretalk is passing the savings directly
on to you the average family saves over
a year when switching is super simple
you can keep your phone keep your number
or get huge discounts on the latest
iphones and androids
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month if you go over on the data
they're not going to charge you for it
from your cell phones i'll pound 250 say
ben shapiro you will save 50
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero say ben shapiro a lot of
phone companies are not particularly
transparent when it comes to what
exactly you are getting for your money
a lot of them will tell you you need
unlimited data you don't what you need
is unlimited talk text and six gigs of
data for 30 bucks a month and again if
you go over
on the data they're not going to charge
you for it you got nothing to lose dial
pound 250 say my name ben
shapiro you will save 50 off your very
first month of coverage
at pure talk usa alrighty so
if you remember all the way back to the
2020 campaign
june 26 2020 the new york times has a
bombshell story
another one of these bombshell stories
that is designed to really harm the
trump white house
and the story is quote russia secretly
offered afghan militants bounties to
kill us troops intelligence says
this is reported by charlie savage eric
schmidt and michael schwartz all three
of whom were deeply involved
in the russiagate nonsense that was
promoted for years that trump was a
cat's paw of the
russian oligarchy according to the new
york times back in
june of 2020 american intelligence
officials have concluded that a russian
military
intelligence unit secretly offered
bounties to taliban-linked militants for
killing coalition forces in afghanistan
including targeting american troops
amid the peace talks to end the
long-running war there according to
officials
briefed on the matter the united states
concluded months ago that the russian
unit which has been linked to
assassination attempts and other covert
operations in europe
intended to destabilize the west or take
revenge on turncoats had covertly
offered rewards
for successful attacks last year and
this became a major issue in the
campaign you'll recall that joe biden
commented on it and suggested that
donald trump was not being harsh enough
with the russians because again
he was in the pocket of the russians and
remember that over and over and over the
media covered this thing in fact
we have a a compendium courtesy of the
daily caller of members of the media
talking up
the bounty scandal in our worldly today
president trump dismissing the russian
bounty intelligence story as a hoax
meant to damage him and republicans
the white house also responding tonight
to a bombshell report accusing russia
of offering bounties to the taliban to
kill american soldiers in afghanistan
and now you know from this reporting in
the new york times which has since been
confirmed by the wall street journal
that not only does the president know
that russia was
paying for american soldiers deaths
get this the washington post is now
reporting that the alleged russian
bounties to taliban fighters in
afghanistan
are believed to have resulted in the
deaths of u.s
troops like this new york times story
about a stunning u.s intel assessment
finding that russia secretly ordered
offered afghan militants bounties
to kill u.s troops okay so this is not
the first story that has been blown
like completely blown by the media as it
turns out it is now being reported that
the intelligence community has very low
confidence that this ever happened
in fact jen sackey admitted this at the
white house yesterday she said yeah we
don't really
think that this is what was happening
they assessed with low to moderate
confidence as you alluded to
that russian intelligence officers
sought to encourage taliban attacks
against u.s and coalition personnel in
afghanistan
the reason that they have low to
moderate confidence in this judgment is
in part
because it relies on detainee reporting
and
due to the challenging environment and
also due to the challenging operating
environment in afghanistan
so it's challenging to gather this
intelligence and this data
okay so it turns out that the story has
very very little to back it
okay trump called it a hoax at the time
he was the head of the white house so
presumably he was being provided with
the intelligence reports the media
immediately called him a liar in fact
the washington post
called it a four pinocchio lie when
trump's not a four pinocchio lie by the
way
when joe biden the current president of
the united states says that jim crow is
now being
reinstituted across the south in the
united states and that black americans
are being forced
to do things like guess the number of
jelly beans
in order to vote the way that they were
back in 1890
right that's not a four pinocchio lie
from the washington post but it was
before pinocchio lie when trump said
that a story that turns out to be
nonsense
was actually a hoax way back when molly
hemingway of the federalist who reported
all the way back then that she was
deeply skeptical of this particular
story that there was nothing to back it
she was mocked
roundly mocked by the media at the time
for suggesting all of that
why because all this pushes the
narrative it's weird how every story the
damage donald trump
was considered perfectly plausible up
until joe biden became president at
which point half those stories fell
apart
right well they're talking about this
story or whether we're talking about
conversations
that trump held with ukraine and it
turns out that some of those
conversations were completely
misreported by the mainstream media
some of them were not but some of them
were it just
there's a there's an effort to suppress
information that is harmful to democrats
and there's an effort to play up
information
that is harmful to republicans even if
that information turns out not to be
true
and that i don't know why americans
would have any sort of faith
in the media to get these things right
it is so easy to launder these stories
through the media now all you need is
basically one source in the intelligence
community
to tell a story to the new york times
and then that same source will
talk to the wall street journal or to
the washington post and they'll tell the
same story and then the washington post
or wall street journal will say we have
confirmed
that this story is true so you can
launder a false story throughout the
media
simply by didn't of having some sort of
connection to the intelligence community
i mean that is deep state kind of stuff
i'm not a big believer in this idea that
there is a conspiratorial cabal within
the intelligence community that's
seeking to oust donald trump but it's
certainly the case that there are a
bunch of people in the intelligence
community who did not like donald trump
and were perfectly happy to harm donald
trump
and many in the media who are perfectly
happy to go along with that and not do
their their actual
footwork in terms of ensuring that the
stories were true in the first place
yesterday at the white house the
reporter asked saki if joe biden felt
any remorse at all
for attacking trump repeatedly over a
story that turns out not to be true
given that assessment does the president
have any regrets for how many times he
attacked president trump on the campaign
about this
issue for not taking action related to
the russian boundaries well i'm not
going to speak to the previous
administration but i will say
that we had enough concern about these
reports
and about the targeting of our men and
women serving uh the men and women who
are proudly serving around the world
that we wanted our intelligence
community to look into it
okay so no there's not gonna be any
apology forthcoming because why would
you apologize the democratic party has
the same mentality as harry reid harry
reid the former senate
minority leader you'll remember that
harry reid said about mitt romney back
in 2012 that he didn't pay any taxes
he had nothing to back that whatsoever
later it came out of course that romney
did pay taxes
and harry reid said didn't matter i was
trying to make him lose at the time this
is the mentality of the media it is
spread throughout social media
as well the latest evidence of this is
that twitter has now banned james
o'keefe why what did what did james
o'keefe do
well his project veritas has been
releasing tape
of cnn directors talking about the bias
at cnn
twitter claimed without evidence
according to the daily wire that o'keefe
was quote violating
the twitter rules on platform
manipulation and spam
according to twitter as outlined in our
policy on platform manipulation and spam
you can't mislead others on twitter by
operating fake accounts and you can
artificially amplify or disrupt
conversations through the use
of multiple accounts o'keefe immediately
said that this is a lie
he called their statement accusing him
of operating fake accounts false he said
i am suing twitter for defamation
donald trump jr responded to twitter's
latest crackdown by saying in case you
haven't figured out how it works by now
cnn spreads propaganda to elect
democrats and then twitter runs
interference to protect cnn
they're all on the same team you
remember that not all that long ago the
claim
was that james o'keefe's material
couldn't be put online because it was
some sort of hacked material because it
was undercover material the same sort of
nonsense that they trotted out there to
explain why they were suppressing the
hunter biden story in the month leading
up to the election the idea there was
this was hacked material we can't allow
hack material which is weird
since you allowed tons and tons of
hacked material throughout the trump
administration and tons and tons of
leaky material throughout the trump
administration
again the real story with james o'keefe
is that o'keefe got cnn producers and
directors to admit on tape that they
basically biased their media coverage in
order to ask trump
but according to twitter the bad guy
here is james o'keefe obviously
and it's not just the o'keefe story that
is now being suppressed
facebook apparently is now blocking
users from sharing another new york post
story what exactly is this new york post
story well the new york post reported
as we talked about on the show that
patrice khan cullers who was one of the
black lives matter
co-founders has now purchased a new 1.4
million dollar home
in a super white area of california
according to media the stories about
khan colors a 37 year old self-described
marxist who spent 3.4 million dollars on
homes last year
and another 1.4 million in march began
in the post on april 10th with the first
one titled marxist blm leader buys 1.4
million
home in ritzy la enclave the daily mail
picked it up black enterprise did so two
days later
with a call from new york city blm chief
hawke newsome calling for an
investigation into where exactly this
money was coming from
when exactly did the media decide to
crack down on this as soon as jason
whitlock
started sharing the story twitter
decided to suspend whitlock for tweeting
out the story
facebook is now banning you from sharing
the new york post story in the first
place in the same way that they banned
you
from sharing the hunter biden story
which is insane
here is facebook's explanation for why
they actually blocked the story quote
the article shared multiple details
which could identify the residents of
one of blm founders in violation or
privacy rights as for our community
standards we do not allow people to post
information
or personal or confidential information
about yourself or of others
we remove content that shares offers or
solicits personally identifiable
information
or other private information that could
lead to physical or financial harm
including financial residential and
medical information as well as private
information obtained from illegal
sources
we also provide ways we also provide
people ways to report imagery they
believe to be in violation of their
privacy rights okay so
all they did in this original story was
they shared a picture
of the house they didn't give the exact
location
this sort of reporting is done literally
all the time all the time in fact
right now online you can find pictures
of the house of the minneapolis officer
who's just brought up on manslaughter
charges
you can find pictures on real estate
sites of the house that i just sold in
california it is not difficult to find
stories
with regard to what people's houses look
like
particularly if they're celebrities and
if they're political celebrities so this
is just a lie
they're suppressing the story because
they don't like the content of the story
this is very this has nothing to do
with the specific methodology of the
story they didn't give out her address
they didn't say go harass her nothing
like that they just printed a story
which is extremely newsworthy
that the marxist founder of a marxist
organization
who suggests that america is deeply
enthralled to white supremacy just
bought a gigantically expensive house
in a super duper white area of
california that's a story
not only is that a story it's a story
with public interest not only is it a
story of public interest it doesn't
threaten her in any way
it does undercut a lot of her claims if
she's so scared of white people if she
believes that white supremacy is really
an institutional
problem that is that is putting black
people in serious danger why in the hell
is she moving to an area with like three
black people
she tripled the black population of
topanga canyon simply by moving there
with members of her family
okay but but it undercuts that it
undercuts the idea that she's an actual
marxist she's not
or maybe she is she's just like stalin
was a marxist right and stalin also had
a nice dasha
everybody else was living in abject
poverty or being slaughtered in ukraine
but he was living
in a really really nice area turns out
this is the way marx has to often work
they get to live in the really nice
house you're the one who has to suffer
nicolas maduro has a really really nice
house
in venezuela so i guess she's just
taking a page from the normal sort of
marxist playbook which is those at the
top of the echelon
they get to have the really nice houses
everybody else has to be a marxist
in any case patrice cullers went on air
with mark lamont hill to try and explain
why she'd been investing you know five
million dollars apparently over the
course of the last year and a half
in real estate pretty non-marxist stuff
there
the the way that i live my life is a
direct support to black people including
my black family members
first and foremost and for so many
black folks who are able to invest
in themselves and their community they
choose to invest in their family
and that's what i've chosen to do i have
a child i have a brother
that has severe mental illness that i
take care of um i support my mother
um and i support many other family
members of mine and so
i see um my money as not my own i see it
as um
my family's money as well oh my god okay
so so she's just a capitalist
she's just a capitalist and not only is
she a capitalist she doesn't believe
that america is a deeply white
supremacist place where white people are
routinely targeting black people
because if she did she wouldn't be
moving out to the out to the boonies
she's moving into
i mean that's topanga canyon is like a
very rich area of l.a
i lived in la for 30 years topanga
canyon is not an impoverished area of
l.a it's not a heavily minority area of
la
i love that it's okay for her to use
millions
of millions of dollars that were taken
in via black lives matter
to supposedly fight the systems of white
supremacy and she proceeded to spill
that money into all the systems of white
supremacy
why in order to protect her found weird
because you know what i have the same
exact view about my money my money is
not just my money it is my family's
money it is not your money patrice
colors it is not the money of black
lives matter it is not the money of the
federal government
it is my money and it is my money and my
family's money and i earn money so that
i can help my family i have exactly the
same view that she does about helping my
family which is why i moved to a safer
area
it's why i moved to a better area and
every single american should have the
same exact right and viewpoint about
their money and their family's money as
patrice colors
it just demonstrates what a damned
hypocrite she is she and her
organization go around
talking about how evil america's systems
of capitalism are tear down the family
weird because here you are
talking about how you are the support
system for your family but i thought
that the family was a patriarchal
terrible structure
which was on the blm website until five
seconds ago i was told
that marxism was the solution to the
problem but here you are talking about
your money and your family's money i
noticed you didn't say the people's
money
i noticed you didn't say that patrice
colors but don't worry it's an
embarrassing story and the media will
step
in to protect patrice colors the the
social media bosses will step in to
protect
patrice i notice they have no sort of
compunction about printing
stories regarding a wide variety of
housing situations for a wide variety of
politicians
but if you step on plm's toes this thing
gets shut down
your establishment media your social
media bosses they are corrupt and by the
way if you're if you believe that this
is all about suppressing
misinformation again there's a
difference between disinformation and
misinformation
social media bosses should not be in the
process should not be
involved in suppressing quote-unquote
misinformation because sometimes what
they perceive to be misinformation is
actually correct
disinformation is active propaganda on
behalf of a foreign power
you'll notice that over the past few
years there's been a subtle shift from
disinformation to misinformation in the
way that the media talk
about information spread online they
went from disinformation is bad
true because it is foreign propaganda to
misinformation is bad which is anything
we don't like is misinformation and
we'll shut it down but i've noticed that
only certain types
of misinformation are being shut down by
the social media bros
i've noticed that i'll give you a
perfect example of misinformation not
being shut down in just one second first
let's talk about the fact you don't want
to go to the auto parts store who wants
to go to the auto parts store i mean you
stand in line forever then you finally
get to the front of the line they ask
you a bunch of questions you don't know
the answer to
you ascertain which part you need and
then they're like hey we don't have that
here we're ordering it online and we're
going to upcharge you for the pleasure
instead why not head over to
rockauto.com rockauto.com is way easier
than doing any of that stuff
they offer the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact parts like for
example let's say you need
just off the top of my head adelphi fg
1456 fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to
2010 honda odyssey
well that'll cost you like 354 bucks at
a big chain store it's the kind of thing
you can get at rock auto for 217 bucks
rockwater.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com right now
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog it's unique
remarkably easy to navigate you're gonna
get the part that you need you're gonna
get it less expensively than you would
at an auto parts store and you're not
gonna have to wait for it the same way
you would by waiting in line head over
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know we sent you
that's rockauto.com
when i talk about the misinformation
that the media simply don't care about
and that social media will not shut down
what if i told you that msnbc's joyride
had on a guest like
last night in which they just suggested
with no evidence whatsoever
that the matt gates scandal which again
has shifted in sort of tone and tender
remember it went from
he was engaged in full-on sex
trafficking to
he was engaging in consensual sex with
adults in perverse ways
it's kind of shifted and moved my view
on this has been the same always
if he's committed criminal activity
bring the evidence and then we'll
go to court that is the way that the
system is supposed to work in any case
joy reid put that aside joy reid and her
guest here suggest
that ron desantis is going to be dragged
into the scandal
based on what based on nothing based on
pulling this directly out of their colon
does this count as misinformation i feel
like it probably should here they are
suggesting that the sitting governor of
florida a probable presidential
candidate in 2024 is going to be dragged
into an unrelated sex scandal
featuring a congress person from florida
because that guy happens to be from
florida
notice if you see somebody's name um
that rings a couple of times
you know at least five women per
politico you had gates um you had a guy
named jason pirasolo the
hand surgeon and gop fundraiser to ron
desantis
um who apparently gates wanted to turn
into the attorney general florida
there's
halsey beshears a former state
legislator
and former appointed official in the
desantis administration
if you're ron desantis does this feel
like it's creeping closer to you because
these are your friends these are your
allies
what in what does it feel like it's
creeping closer to you
matt getz is is a matt gates is a
republican
in florida he presumably uses the same
fundraising network as pretty much all
the republicans in florida just like the
same democratic fundraisers
fundraise for a bunch of democrats does
it feel like it's coming close to
in what way explain like seriously do
you have any sort of linkage whatsoever
except for the fact
that florida is a giant state with 21
million people in it and the republican
politicians tend to fundraise from the
same people
that is the weakest link of evidence
i've ever heard in my entire life
and dreary's just throwing it out there
does it feel like the gate scandal is
going to approach around descent i know
you guys have thrown everything
including the kitchen sink at ron
desantis and you have failed because
your misinformation campaign against
desantis
is disgusting and terrifying i mean you
just keep throwing out false headlines
about his answers oh he's gonna kill
everybody at the jacksonville beaches
oh he was probably rolling out this
publix vaccine thing because he was paid
a hundred thousand dollars into a super
pac by publix
sure publix happens to be the single
most populous grocery line in all of
florida
but it was really about the hundred
thousand dollar donation guys it's
probably about that oh well he was
probably falsifying his death statistics
sure you have no evidence he was
falsifying his death statistics
well you know probably we should listen
to this this crazy lady who used to work
for the
florida health services and was fired
because she's actually a terrible
employee and also kind of a congenital
liar apparently
like you guys have tried to go after his
hands down everything so now the last
ditch attempt here
from joy reid is trying to link him to
the matt gates scandal now i've noticed
there's been no blowback for joy read on
this
none no one's commented on this no one
cares imagine for a second
that joe biden were linked to i don't
know like his actual son
his actual son who in text messages was
talking about the big guy receiving 10
of particular businesses and was going
around jet setting
around the world picking up bags of cash
for no reason other than his last name
is biden well being a complete scuzz bag
on the personal front
and let's say that the new york post
reported that a month before the
election
social media cracked down on that right
that was a bad thing we were told that
that was russian
misinformation that it was hacked
material that it was all dangerous
american people should not be able to
even distribute that story we're being
told that patrice colors we shouldn't
know
that she actually bought another house
what is that her third house she bought
another house in in
the whitest area of l.a we shouldn't
know that stuff because that stuff is
dangerous to know
but if we're just gonna go speculating
like joy reid's gonna go speculating
about ron desantis being dragged into a
sex scandal with no evidence whatsoever
that's totally cool
it's totally fine this is the way your
establishment media work if it damages
the republican
it doesn't have to be true it doesn't
even have to be credible it just has to
be an
accusation and then you run with the
headline accusations made
you'll remember they did the exact same
thing with the steele dossier the steele
dossier was never
verified by any member of the media
instead what happened is that james
comey went and briefed trump on the
steele dossier and then cnn reported
james comey has briefed trump on the
steele dossier and then buzzfeed was
like what is this deal dossier boom
here's the steele dossier and we get
years of speculation about pee
tapes because of this nonsense you know
that
i mentioned on the air a few days ago
this piece by margaret sullivan
from the washington post talking about
how the american people hold no values
in common with journalists because
journalists like transparency
and they like information seeking and
they like objectivity no the american
people don't like the media because the
media are damned liars and they are just
political partisans on behalf of the
democratic party
they are propagandists at this point if
you trust these people further than you
can throw them i don't know what to tell
you you're a fool
you're a fool alrighty now we get to the
other
big story of the day and that is the
continuing narrative that is pushed
by the media with regard to the police
so the continuing narrative over and
over and over is that the police are
systemically racist that every
individual anecdotal incident
involving a white police officer and a
black suspect that goes bad
every one of those is evidence that
black americans are an existential
threat in the united states once again
there is no statistical evidence that
black americans are an existential
threat in the united states
none black americans represent 13 of the
population of the united states meaning
they're about 40 million black americans
every year there are fewer than 25 black
americans who are shot unarmed by the
police
that is not an existential threat to
black americans you're far more likely
in black america to be killed by a
fellow black
person then you are to be killed by a
white cop and if you're a white cop by
the way you are significantly more
likely to be killed by a black american
then you are likely to kill
a black american in the line of duty
by the way that inter-group violence
thing that's true intra-group violence
and that is true of every single racial
group in america with the exception of
asian americans who are most likely to
be targeted according to fbi statistics
by black americans if you're white
you're not most likely to be targeted by
a black person you're most likely to be
targeted by a white person
if you are black you're most likely to
be targeted by a black person in your
community and if you're talking about ex
extraordinary rates of murder in the
black community and what are the real
threats to black life in america the
police rank extremely low on that list
and the absence of police
ironically ranks extremely high on the
list because it turns out that when the
police leave
more people shoot each other regardless
of race
okay so the that is not the narrative of
the media the narrative of the media is
that the police are the existential
threat
to black americans chelsea handler that
dolt she tweeted out the other day
that why would she obey police orders
when there's like a 50 50 shot
that even if you obey police orders
you're gonna get shot it's like
that statistic is pulled directly out of
her ass she had to remove her head from
her ass in order to get to the stat
a 50 50 shot of being shot by the cops
if you comply with orders
there are 40 million 40 million police
interactions with suspects in the united
states every year
40 million civilian police interactions
again the number of black unarmed
americans shot
and killed by the police every year is
fewer than 30.
according to the washington post
database that is not a 50 50 shot gang
okay but the narrative has to be
promulgated because the narrative is
more important than the data the
narrative is more important than the
reality the narrative
that you are powerless in your own life
if you're a black american that you're
living at the mercy of systems beyond
your control
that the only way that you are going to
ever live free
in the united states is by abdicating
responsibility and abdicating power to a
giant government apparatus that is going
to save you
it's a lie but it is the narrative of
the democratic party and it's forwarded
by every aspect of your media
from the trevor noah's of the world to
your mainstream
establishment media here is trevor noah
the other day
suggesting that there are no good apples
in the police where he says you know we
keep hearing about bad apples but there
are no good apples
in the no good apples 40 million
interactions between cops and civilians
every year in the united states
no good apples my god i mean the the
utter the sheer
ingratitude and arrogance of people like
trevor noah who is sitting in a
in his house presumably with enough
security that he doesn't feel threatened
by his neighbors
who is living presumably in a very
upscale area with a solid police force
saying there are no good apples and the
cops is pretty astonishing
where are the good apples if we're meant
to believe
that the police system in america the
system of policing itself is not
fundamentally broken
then we would need to see good apples
and by the way
i'm not saying that there are no good
policemen don't get me wrong
i'm asking where the good apples are we
don't see a mass uprising of police
saying let's root out these people we
don't see
videos of police officers stopping the
other cop from pushing an old man at a
black lives matter protest or from
beating up a kid in the street with a
baton we don't see that so my question
is
where are the good apples we're not
dealing with bad apples
we're dealing with a rotten tree oh the
entire tree is rotten so
okay and that's the narrative right the
narrative is that the cops are entirely
rotten
the entire system is completely rotten
and every anecdotal piece of evidence
that comes down the line
is then misinterpreted by the media in
order to achieve this outcome
that every incident that the the
anecdotal evidence that you see in a
george floyd tape
or that you see in a dante write case
those statistically very very rare
incidents
those particularly rare incidents are
indicative of the entire policing
structure of the united states
this is the way by the way that so much
of our of our sort of
race conscious writing is done and
commentary is done in this country it's
every tanahasi coates article right
every town of haaseco's article is
here's a terrible thing that happens in
1890 fast forward to 2021 nothing has
changed and we just skipped the entire
civil rights movement we skipped the
civil rights act we skipped the
growth of the black middle class we skip
the fact that we've had a black
president twice the fact we skipped like
all the things we just go direct from
1890 to 2021.
by the way there's a a thought
experiment that i sometimes
enjoy doing if an alien looked at
america in 1890 and then looked at
america in 2021 do you think that that
alien would have said look things look
exactly the same
because if that alien said that that
alien would be mentally ill
if you were just a a person who came
down from space and you looked at
america 1890
black people and white people drinking
at separate water fountains black people
no policing
none one of the reasons that you have
higher rates of black homicide in the
united states according to my soul
is because deliberately of racist under
policing in the black community
there was a view in the white community
the racist white community in 1890 1880
well you know if black people kill each
other we don't care so we're not even
going to send the cops in there
and there there was no intermarriage i
mean the levels of intermarriage between
black and white in 1890 were essentially
non-existent because it was illegal in
large swathes of the united states
fast forward to 2021 huge amounts of
intermarriage between the races
black people have been president black
people have been secretary of state
black people are on the supreme court
black americans are at the highest
levels of america's industry black
americans are outvoting their percentage
of the popul like to pretend that
there's been no progress but that's how
tahasi codes does
his shtick right he just skips all of
the intervening data to pretend that
nothing has changed
that's the great lie and it's pushed
also by by idiots like nicole hannah
jones over the new york times okay and
now you get that same sort of stuff
being done with the police
here are a couple of anecdotal instances
of things that are either controversial
so we don't even know that they're bad
yet we don't have all the information
either controversial
or bad and we take those pieces of
anecdotal evidence and then we attribute
it to the system broadly speaking
by the way this is how you get to
terrible stereotypes honestly you want
to talk about how people get to racism
how people get terrible terrible
stereotypes they take pieces of
anecdotal evidence that they have in
their lives
about people of a particular race acting
badly and then they attribute them to
the entire group
and that's exactly what you're seeing
trevor noah do right here right trevor
noah is saying
i've seen a tape of a police officer
doing a bad thing must be that all
people who wear that uniform are bad
where are the good apples says trevor
noah and there are no good apples
because the tree
is rotten and the latest example that is
being used today
is this situation in chicago in which a
13 year old kid and he has a kid because
there's no such thing as a 13 year old
man
he was again again two things can be
true at once he's a kid
kids are generally not responsible for
their actions because they're children
also any sort of social and cultural
system that generates 13 year olds
running around at 3 a.m
holding guns and being called baby
diablo as members of a gang that is a
broken cultural system that is a very
broken cultural system anyway this kid
is running around his name is adam
toledo running around carrying a gun
apparently there were shots fired and
the police were called to scene
and this kid because he's a kid ran away
okay and the and politicians
politicians have been saying this is a
deliberate shooting of an unarmed
blackhead
that is not true we have the body cam
footage if the body
but the body cam footage is going to
make no difference the media have a
narrative to push they're going to
continue to push the narrative no matter
what the actual body cam footage shows
in the same way that they're actually
ignoring the fact that the dante write
case is a pretty obvious case of an
accident the officer shouts taser taser
taser shoots dante wright
and then immediately says oh my god i
shot him that is the most obvious body
cam footage i've ever seen
of a person who mistook a taser for a
gun that was not a purposeful first
degree murder that was not i shot him
and i'm covering up for it by pretending
i was going for my taser that is none of
that the media have run with the idea
that perhaps it was a murder anyway
they're doing the exact same thing in
the atom toledo case
let me get to this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact
that free email services like gmail and
yahoo they're not really free
you pay with your privacy in fact
internet giants like big tech bank on
exploiting your data by selling it to
the highest bidder
start mail keeps my email private period
every email can be encrypted even if the
recipient doesn't use encryption
when you delete an email in start mail
it is gone forever and start mail uses
their own servers not amazon's which
means they cannot be put out of business
the way that amazon
put parlor out of business switching to
start mail is seamless you can easily
transfer all your current email data so
there's no starting from scratch
start mail is also backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited anonymous aliases this
feature protects your main email address
from spam and phishing attacks when
you're starting to give your email to a
company but want to protect your
identity
start mail can generate a shareable
alias email so people can't sell your
information
and they can be deleted at any time your
cyber security has never been more at
risk why would you trust the tech bros
with your most private information
instead
start securing your email privacy today
with start mail sign up today you get 50
off your first year go to startmail.com
that is start mail.com ben s-t-a-r-t
mail.com for 50 off your first year
honestly i can't imagine
many more important internet services
than having an email server you can
trust startmail.com
ben all right we're going to get to the
actual body cam footage in the atom
toledo case in one second first it is
that glorious time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily wire member
today congratulations to dylan kilmann
on instagram who understands the
importance of instilling solid values in
kids in this picture
dylan's adorable son aiden stands
proudly holding two examples of the
world's most exclusive and well-crafted
tumblr the caption reads
trying to teach him how to appreciate
only the finest drinking vessels hashtag
leftist tears at tumblr
that is some excellent dadding right
there thanks for the pick thanks for
being a daily wire member
now here's the thing yesterday's
troubling events between twitter and
project veritas should concern everybody
left right and center is becoming
easier and easier for big tech to just
silence people they view as problematic
it's going to get worse and worse before
it gets better
it's one of the principal reasons why
the daily wire embraces a
membership-based business model
you saw they kicked james o'keefe off
twitter you see how they're attempting
to suppress information
at facebook we cannot become reliant on
big tech we cannot be subject to their
arbitrary whims
every new member who joins us makes us a
little bit less dependent on big tech
you're helping us
ensure that we don't go off air you're
helping us ensure that they cannot take
us offline
building up our membership base is the
only way to ensure the daily wire can
continue to grow and thrive into the
future so
if you're a daily ware member already
thank you we appreciate you you're the
best if you're not a daily wire member
what are you doing
join us today in fact it's so vital that
we quickly build up our membership base
we are offering 25 off new memberships
when you use the code
censorship at dailywire.com subscribe
we don't just want your support we want
to keep bringing you new awesome content
like tonight's episode of candace with
candace owens his latest guest adam
corolla
there are also some pretty good hunter
biden jokes tonight's episode streams
live at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central on
dailywire.com
if you aren't a member you get the audio
podcast kansas it drops saturdays on
apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcast so remember for a limited time
get 25
off a new membership when you use code
censorship at dailywire.com
subscribes a great deal keep us from
being dependent on big tech so we can
keep bringing you the news and content
you want and you need you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so let's get to this body cam
footage so one of the nice things about
body cams that we actually have evidence
of what goes on
in these shooting scenarios apparently
the police were called because adam
toledo who is the
13 year old kid in this case was one of
several
youths who were shooting guns at 3 a.m
in the morning
you know we've seen too many stories by
the way in places like chicago of kids
being hit by stray bullets
it's dangerous you're not supposed to
shoot guns at any time in chicago
randomly and you're certainly not
supposed to shoot at 3am in the morning
the question that nobody has the actual
balls to ask here is where are the
parents
where are the parents who lets a 13 year
old run around with a gun at 3am in the
morning
where the hell is the system that is
supposed to prevent all of this from
happening where's the social system
that's supposed to prevent all of this
from happening in any case
this kid is running from the cops the
cop is chasing the kid
and you can see the body cam footage now
the way this was originally reported was
unarmed black kid shot
that is not true okay it is not true the
kid is running
finally the kid stops and the police
officer says turn around and drop the
gun
the kid has his hand behind him okay it
is very difficult
from the body cam footage to see where
he drops the gun so you assume that the
officer has the same vantage point
so the kid has the gun sort of on his
right hip he reaches behind him
he drops the gun and raises his hands in
one motion
he drops the gun directly behind him and
raises his hands in one motion but
because his hand is behind him when he
drops the gun and when he starts to
raise his hand
by the time his hand begins to raise the
shot has been fired the shot gets fired
before his hand is all the way up to the
top of his head because this is a it's
literally a bang bang scenario
okay now cops are not robots the kid did
have a gun
if you drop the gun right before the cop
shoots you it is very difficult to call
that unarmed this is very reminiscent of
that case in baltimore recently
in which the the the suspect
threw away the gun and in the same
motion as he's running he throws away
the gun and gets shot at exactly the
same time it looks very much like this
so the still that has gone out for from
the media
is the still of the kid raising his
hands as he's being shot
but they don't go to literally a split
second beforehand
right if you're around this a split
second what you'll see is the kid's hand
behind his hip
right there it's behind his hip and you
will see that he has a gun in his hand
behind him
right so how is a cop supposed to deal
with that
when the hand is obscured he's not
facing him when the hand is obscured
behind his hip and he raises his hand
you don't know whether the gun is coming
up with him in his hand
there's a reason why even cnn legal
analysts were like this is a good shoot
they're like what what are you supposed
to do if you're a cop
are we supposed to tell cops that
they're just supposed to take the shot
like are they
are they just supposed to receive the
shot what exactly are they supposed to
do right here so the media have decided
this is yet another murder
of a young person in chicago based on
race of course
okay that that is an absurd contention
there is the evidence on that again is
just as scanty as the evidence that
dante wright was shot because of race
or not by accident hey but here's the
thing the evidence does not matter for
the narrative
in the end the evidence does not matter
for the narrative perfectly indicative
case of this
there's a woman named christine emba who
writes a column for the washington post
and her piece over at the washington
post is titled why i'm not watching the
jarrett chauvin trial and it's such a
telling piece
because basically what it says is i
don't want to hear any extraneous
evidence that might change my mind
that's basically the piece the piece is
i already know what happened i'm not
going to listen to anybody who descends
from my belief about what happened
including the actual evidence in the
case she says confession i set up most
of the derek chauvin trial well not sat
it out exactly the internet and cable
news exist
so it's impossible to avoid reports of
the testimony the prosecution witnesses
tears
and the defenses scramble for any
possible way to paper over the truth
that we all saw with our own eyes
oh you mean the defense laid out a
defense is what you're talking about and
also it's not papering over the truth
when you present medical experts who
testify as to derek as to
what derek chovin was doing with his
knee not on the neck what derek chauvin
what george floyd's medical state was
during the actual
case but doesn't none of that matters
christina says to be honest i sat it out
because i'm black
i'm tired and because i know i will have
the chance to see it or something like
it again
the trial could have been a moment of
national catharsis at least that's what
pundits hoped and politicians begged for
after the protest of last summer police
department fainted becoming more kind
solemn statements from state houses and
courthouse steps instead it became mere
background
to more of the same this sunday as the
trial paused police in brooklyn center
minnesota
pulled over dante wright while he was
driving citing a traffic violation
air freshener hanging from his rearview
mirror wright told his mother an expired
tag the police department said by the
way it was not the air freshener
it was the expired dad by the visual
evidence either way not capital offenses
right attempted to get back into his car
and a police officer shot him to death
allegedly she mistook her gun for her
taser she has at least resigned him and
charged with manslaughter we mean at
least
that's called the system working okay
the system would work better if she
followed procedure
but when the system does not work
there's a secondary system called the
justice system she's now in it
she's been charged with second-degree
manslaughter and what does this i love
that she says
that it is clear from the evidence of
our own eyes that derek shove and murder
george floyd but it is not clear
from the objectively clear body cam
footage
that she mistook her gun for a taser
it's the clearest thing
on body cam footage doesn't matter
that's a legend but derek shoving
killing george floyd not alleged that's
just reality
says christine emba of the of the
washington post
she says the brooklyn's police
department's response to protests was to
string up a thin blue line flag above
the building removing it only after an
outcry online
minnesota governor tim walls the
democrat threatened to send in the
largest police president in minnesota
history to arrest and charge those
protesting the fact that a 20 year old
was shot dead by the police
that's not even true because these are
just they're just lies tim wall's a
democrat
tim walls pledged to send in cops to
stop
rioting and looting not protests so
she's just lying again the narrative
matters way more than the fact for a lot
of the folks in the media
as if this isn't the mo as if this isn't
the most american response as we saw in
dc and across the united states last
summer
the people want fewer police send more
of them who are the people
by polling data that's not true by
polling data the people actually want
the same or more police
by all polling data i've ever seen
de-escalation training how about we
militarize them and said
investment in communities how about a
robot police dog to terrify and harass
you as if the real ones aren't
frightening
yes that's that's what's happening we're
we're creating the hound from fahrenheit
451.
that's clearly like number one priority
floyd's death and chauvin's trial could
be teaching america a lesson but it is
clearly not one that all of us are ready
to learn
okay this is this is my favorite part of
the article from christine emba because
once again it just demonstrates that
evidence does not matter
data do not matter all that matters is
the narrative that's all that matters
feckless legislators are trying out old
arguments against those who seek reform
and police conduct
the real problem is black criminality
the police don't deserve all this
trouble
well how about this how about there are
several problems really
resisting arrest is a problem police
being poorly trained as in the dante
right case
that is a problem right failure to get
rid of bad cops when they have many
complaints against them that are
justified
that's a problem there can be many
problems and it turns out that
criminality is indeed a problem when you
are talking
about confrontations between police and
suspected criminals
well here here's the best part of the
article so christina emba says in the
words of senator john neely kennedy
republican of louisiana
the next time you get in trouble call a
crackhead and she writes this this is
the line
well maybe i will they're statistically
less likely to shoot me it would seem
now this is my that's my favorite line i
have a question
based on what is she saying that
seriously based on what is she saying
that a crackhead is less likely to shoot
her statistically than a cop
she doesn't provide any stat she just
says they are statistically less likely
to shoot me it would seem no stat cited
okay that's not what the word
statistically means statistically
generally is followed by you know a
statistic
typically but that doesn't matter she
can just say statistically that you are
safer with a crackhead than a cop so i
asked christine emba do you want to go
hang out with crackheads or at the
police house
you get to pick one tonight which one do
you think is going to be safer for you a
columnist for the washington post
a a crack house or a or a police
headquarters
which one pretty obvious answer here but
it doesn't matter because that's
contradictory to the narrative just like
it's contradictory to the narrative that
police colors decided to buy in the
whitest area of la
as opposed to plunking down her flag in
the middle of south central
los angeles the minute she could move
away
from crime-ridden areas she did
okay that how people at quick rule of
social science how people act
is significantly significantly more
telling than what people say they think
about things
every self every self survey has a bias
toward people who are who are taking the
self survey if you ask people how well
they did on their sats they will just
lie
if you ask watch if you take a poll
today because biden won how many people
say they voted for biden
it'll actually be higher than the number
of people who voted for biden in the
last election cycle
because people have a tendency to
flatter themselves they're on the right
side of history
or that they make all of these good
moral decisions but then you watch what
they do and it's completely different
when you say things like you trust
crackheads more than cops i just i don't
i don't believe you i think you're a
liar
when you suggest that you are happier in
a high crime area than in a low crime
area because that low crime area is
predominantly white and white supremacy
rules the roost and then you move to the
white low crime area i feel like that's
more telling about what you actually
think about the world than
what you say on the blm website or your
latest appearance on rachel maddow
the evidence the data they don't matter
you know what actually matters
the narrative that's all that matters
because it's about tearing down the
institutions of the united states and
that is continuing a pace among the
democrats and in the media
it is continuing every single day the
attempt to tear down these institutions
and to justify tearing down the
institutions by claiming that america's
institutions need to be torn down
this is why joe biden and the democratic
party are now pushing court packing
they're now
realistically speaking are they going to
pack the court no they don't have the
power to do so they can't do it through
reconciliation
which means they need a filibuster-proof
majority even if they could do it
through reconciliation
do you really think that kristen cinema
who's in a very purple state in arizona
and joe manchin in a very red state west
virginia are going to vote to simply add
seats to the supreme court the answer is
no but it's all about pushing a
narrative the narrative being that the
supreme court is an institutional
obstacle to you getting what you want
so vote for democrats right that is the
goal of democrats here is to cast the
supreme court which by the way is the
only branch of american government
that americans broadly trust taking the
supreme court and grinding it under your
ideological boot heal that is the goal
here not actually changing the supreme
court
uh jen sackey said yesterday joe biden
is now open to court packing which is
weird because he wouldn't answer that
question throughout the entire campaign
and in fact if you asked him the
question you were told that you were
being too harsh on joe biden
they're going to look at a number of
issues the size of the court is one of
the issues but there are a number of
other issues they'll look at
i'm sure the president will look forward
to reviewing
that report when it comes to his desk
and then i'm sure it will impact his
thinking moving forward but
we don't know what that report will look
like and he obviously can still make the
decision about what he supports
i mean who knows who by the way is the
same joe biden who just a few years ago
was saying
that it was corrupt to pack the supreme
court my favorite part of this is how
the media just go right along with it
let me just go right
along with it so jerry nadler laid out
the most orwellian
perversion of language of the last you
know seven minutes because they just
keep perverting language
remember when sexual preference went
from just a term to describe whether you
are gay or straight to a slur because
mazie hirono in hawaii said that it was
a slur
they're doing the same thing now so now
jerry nadler says when you pack the
supreme court you're actually unpacking
the supreme court
as david burge iowa hawk on twitter said
yeah and
when i crash into my truck into a
7-eleven
it's actually when i pull out that's
actually uncrashing my truck
into a 7-eleven that's the part to focus
on here's jerry and adler claiming when
you add seats to the supreme court
you're actually unpacking the supreme
court
it's a proper number it matches the
number of circuits as it has
historically
and it also will enable us to do justice
and to rectify the great injustice
that was done in packing the court and
some people will say we're packing the
court we're not packing it we're
unpacking it
senator mcconnell and the republicans
packed the court over the last couple of
years
as senator uh marky outlined so this is
a a a reaction to that we just changed
the definitions packing is unpacking
healthcare is infrastructure like the
language just randomly changes
that's all and it all changes in
accordance with the democratic agenda
because that's all that matters agenda
agenda
uber alice effectiveness does not matter
truth does not matter data does not
matter
all that matters is what the utopian
left wants to do and what they have to
break that's in their way
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
otherwise
we'll see you here next week also you
can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you as
always on fridays
head on over to dailywire.com this
evening 7 pm eastern tune and i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin